and now as we were just saying yesterday
of course the 50th pride in london
parade where thousands of lgbt people
and supporters protested and celebrated
in the streets of london and in 1984 at
a rally in rugby against a possible ban
on gay council employees chris smith
said good afternoon i'm chris smith i'm
the labour mp for islington south and
finsbury and i am gay he instantly
became the first openly gay mp in the
house of commons there are now of course
dozens uh in a further landmark moment
he also became the first openly gay
member of the cabinet uh we can now
speak to chris smith uh or lord smith we
should say he's also master of pembroke
college cambridge and he joins us now um
how difficult was the decision you made
in 1984 and what was the reaction oh i
was absolutely scared stiff i
uh partly because no one had ever done
this before
i it was a spur of the moment decision i
had decided that at some point i wanted
to say something about myself
because i think it's much more important
to be open and honest
about who and what you are um when
you're a public representative um
but
the only question was when was the right
moment to do it and i can remember
walking into the hall in rugby uh about
a thousand people packed into the hall
and as i walked up to take my seat on
the platform i just thought
this is the moment to do it and
i have to say the next 10 minutes before
i stood up
were some of the scariest of my life i
my hands were shaking my knees were
knocking together i i had no idea what
the response was going to be
and what was then what was the response
do you think
um uh well the uh in the hall it was
ecstatic and uh the the uh
entire audience got to their feet and
gave me a standing ovation um
it's the only time i've ever had a
standing ovation 30 seconds into a
speech
um but uh
the um
the the best thing that happened
was
in the week or so afterwards i got
letters from all around the country um
this was long before the days of social
media um so people wrote letters and
i i got uh hundreds of letters
some of which said uh well done
congratulations um
but the ones that i think made the most
to me
were the ones that said
thank you
this has made it easier for me
as you say i can really imagine how
those ones must have just been
you know quite an incredible thing to
receive really
and to know that you have made a
difference in that way um of course back
in 1984 you were the only openly a gay
mp in parliament now there are i think
60 mps have openly said that they are
lgbt
and but despite the progress that has
clearly been made i was just talking
about this with justin greening as well
homophobic hate crime is actually
increasing and how concerned are you
about that and do you think that you
know some progress is perhaps not as
easy as we assume i'm uh i'm very
concerned about
the bullying that goes on in schools the
abuse that people get to the homophobic
hate crime
that has been happening and we have only
to think for example about the stephen
port case to
to know that there is still a serious
problem out there
but
in many ways we have made a lot of
progress
a lot of legislation has been changed uh
there are now as you say huge numbers of
openly gay members of parliament um
we see other public figures coming out
the young
footballer who recently came out for
example
incredibly brave
wonderful moment
for him and for the lgbt community um so
at the same time as
the
homophobic abuse is happening you also
have considerable progress being made
and
we just have to keep on steadily making
the progress not taking anything for
granted
not allowing the government for example
to get away with omitting trans people
from the ban on conversion therapy
we we need to campaign for lgbt rights
around the rest of the world um
many countries
with a legacy of colonial administration
from the uk have kept victorian laws on
their statute books um
there's a huge amount
still to be done
but
we also need to be
we need to be glad about what has
happened and what we have been able to
achieve
and that's why a moment like celebrating
the 50th anniversary of pride is so
important
um to your right and while i've got you
just finally um the news today of course
is dominated by yet another sexual
misconduct scandal chris pincher just
the latest
resignation
what do you think was worse the sleaze
scandal under john major or the one that
the conservative party is currently
going through
oh this is infinitely worse um
the um
because there is just so much of it and
it's not just the occasional um
looking at a
porn in the house of commons on your
iphone or furtively
groping
young men in the carlton club
it's not just those sort of things
it's the scandal the real scandal of all
the contracts which were issued in a
hurry to untested untried companies um
uh in the first outbreaks of of kovid
it's the um
the ignoring of the law of the country
so frequently in downing street
there's a whole litany of stuff it is
infinitely worse than it was before
infinitely worse uh there you go thank
you so much for coming on the program it
was lovely to hear uh your story about
what happened when you first decided to
come out so thank you so much thank you
very much